foreign
[Music]
keep going
under Center
after a while
especially the security UK they're going
to start
uh
going into that
oppositional thinking so they they will
unconsciously counter the technique in
various ways okay
once once you have a foundation though
you can use that and you can actually
bring your guasa into
or even into it drill like poke Dosa
okay so uh
you'll see like you'll get here and uh
he's he's lifting up
but let's say he he smells that fall you
see and you'll be able to tell that he's
gonna let this energy
go over the top of him because he's
Gonna Roll
I'm Gonna Roll
yes
he let he smells the role and he lets
that energy a little bit
and now if you task yourself as I have
tasked you which is to get underneath
his Center
he's gonna counter that in his little
role
take more energy off of this hand and
it'll punch you in the face if you don't
there you go
so when you feel that do you see that's
when you have to change it you have to
change it to find the center
so you can tell oh he's gonna go there
or uh maybe you notice ah
and under and he went under it again you
see so here I come
use his mind against it you see that and
now it is
kilon
but you have a giwaza
it's an element to it
okay
foreign
[Applause]
okay let's go
foreign
[Music]
so your Kimmy should not be beginner
progression you can
which means
okay
so let's just watch what you did you're
gonna do it again
okay so I'm gonna fall into the gym I'm
gonna fall into the end
I don't go here
and then you start to come back and then
I start to take the kidney
I go ahead and keep my Center in my
hands and you have to project that
yes
do you understand
so that way
if you followed in
month that's when my movements can be
very small oh
can you push your hardness
well I go like this Jason and then you
feel that you go into the room to me
that's a counter
do you understand and then you make some
silent agreement if I take you here I
expect you to follow them
so I take you there that's how I can do
that
but if you're gonna go flying backwards
at the slightest you get it look what
happens
you're coming in and I should be able to
bounce that off the ground
if they need to be very small
you're always pushing with your whole
Mass
do you understand boom
push performance
whole Mass every time
get up hold mess oh
all maps
okay
ready okay
let's go
thank you
foreign
[Music]
go into her Center
keep pushing
into the center with your torso
keep your arms put your Center in your
arms
You Tristan push down in your arms yes
yes Center in your arms
keep falling into your hands
four attempt four attempts
[Music]
keep falling into your hands
in the center
[Music]
that the young hands is over the center
yield
Center
[Music]
foreign
good
as the more I feel he's gone I got to
resist the urge to push on it okay I
release
very relaxed okay